den impuls für die wissenschaft ihr
braucht nicht unbedingt ein pool eine
badewanne tut's auch um spaß hier zu
beobachten
krump liebesdinge und sehen wie kommt
das rumpeln zustande und wurzel ist es
gut zunächst fällt auf dass nur die haut
an den fingern und zehen es rumpelt am
rest des körpers nicht allgemein ist die
haut an den händen und füßen anders als
im rest des körpers sticker es wachsen
keine härchen und sie hat die höchste
dichte an berührungs rezeptor lange
dachte man dass sich die haut beim
schrumpeln einfach nur mit wasser
versorgt doch ganz so einfach ist es
nicht wenn das rumpeln nicht nur rechts
auf sein kommen würde dann wäre die
sogenannte osmose daran schuld
die salzkonzentration in meinem körper
ist höher sb im pullmann sagt auch der
osmotische druck in meinem körper ist
höher als der im pool eindruck
unterschied möchte immer ausgeglichen
werden dazu gibt es zwei möglichkeiten
entweder das seit aus meinem körper 200
in den pool doch das lässt meine haut
nicht so oder das was aus dem pool
wandert in meinen körper also meine
finger
deswegen ist der effekt auch viel
geringer wenn man in mehr bahn geht
dabei salzwasser durch betrug für
dasselbe gilt übrigens auch für pools
mit sehr viel chlor am besten könnte den
effektor ich zu hause in der badewanne
beobachten doch die theorie mit dem
osmotischen druck ist nur die halbe
wahrheit sagen neurologe menschen bei
denen die nerven beschädigt sind können
so lange im pool oder der badewanne
liegen wie sie wollen oder dass die
finger schmutzig werden neurologen sind
davon überzeugt dass beschränken der
finger weniger ein passives auffüllen
sondern mehr eine aktive reaktion des
nervensystems ist bei längerem kontakt
mit wasser sorgt das sogenannte
sympathische nervensystem dafür dass
sich winzige blutgefäße in den fingern
und den zehn zusammenziehen und damit
die haut nach innen ziehen so für den
stromsektor
aber wozu jetzt das ganze englische
forscher fanden heraus dass man mit
rubriken fingern glatte objekte im
wasser besser greifen kann
die rillen
die profile beim reifen wozu jetzt aber
schrumpelige 10 gut sind
das gilt es herauszufinden oder
vielleicht habt ihr eine idee schreibt
in die kommentare
schön schlau und damit ist unser
wunderschöner urlaub in italien leider
auch schon fast vorbei wenn ihr einfach
eindrücke davon haben wollt dann schaut
in unser letztes video nächste woche
geht es weiter im wunderschönen
deutschland bis dahin bleibt sicher